bonjour je suis ingénieur et depuis six
ans je travaille sur des projets de
développement au bangladesh et il ya
deux ans je suis parti sur ce bateau
pour une expédition de six mois dans les
îles désertes du golfe du bengale
six mois avec un objectif vivre en
autonomie sur ce bateau voilà mon plan
j'avais aménagé à l'avant du bateau une
serre pour faire pousser des patates à
l'arrière un poulailler avec deux poules
poule rousse et paul blanche pour avoir
des oeufs du matériel de pêche pour
pêcher de poisson un réchaud à bois pour
cuire le tout l'idée c'était de manger
donné les restos poule donné les fientes
de poule aux patates manger des patates
et c'est comme un petit écosystème et au
moment du départ je pensais que six mois
après j'allais revenir avec plus de
nourriture qu'au départ en fait ça s'est
pas passé exactement comme prévu
au bout de deux trois semaines les plans
de patates dans la serre sont devenus
tout mou et puis ils sont morts en fait
après devenu tout dur les poules rousset
pour le blanche à l'arrière était hyper
stressé parce que leur poulailler été
accrochés suspendue au dessus de l'eau
une poule n'a pas l'habitude de vivre
dans des situations comme ça et du coup
à chaque fois que je m'arrêter sur une
des îles désertes gd promenait sur la
plage pour les détendre un peu dans
l'espoir qu'elle fonde et c'est comme ça
que poule rousse et paul blancho
disparue dans la jungle sur une petite
île de l'indonésie en mémoire de
toulouse
le réchaud à bois par contre lui
marchait très bien
le problème c'est que quand je
m'arrêtais sur les îles désertes pour
ramasser du bois pour le réchaud en même
temps j'ai ramassé des contenus dans du
bois des familles de termites
quand envahi tout le bateau et qu'on
bouffe et le mac est en bambou qui s'est
cassé dans une tempête au large de
sumatra
bon enfin en gros assez vite dès les
premiers mois j'ai compris que j'avais
pas atteindre mon objectif d'autonomie
et comme pourtant j'avais été très
confiant au départ au démarrage et que
j'avais pas embarquer assez de
nourriture pour les six mois mais j'ai
eu des vrais problèmes de carences de
malnutrition et enfin en gros j'avais
faim quand je suis revenu en france
après les six mois avec l'équipe de mon
association
on a fouillé sur internet pour essayer
de trouver quelle technologie j'aurais
pu développer avec les moyens du bord
pour atteindre mes objectifs et on a été
super étonné de voir le nombre de
solutions possibles je vous en donne
quelques unes
ça c'est sur des sites de randonneurs
qu'on a trouvé ça c'est un réchaud à
l'économie de bois y en a qui l'appelle
neo ce tome le principe c'est que ça
joue sur la double combustion du bois le
bois quand il chauffe à plus de 400
degrés il émet un gaz qui sort par des
petits trous dans la chambre de
combustion quiero qui longe les parois
et qui est brûlé en priorité sur le bois
c'est la pyrolyse dubois et ça ça divise
par sept la consommation en bois et par
quatre l'émission de fumée toxique si
j'avais vu ça sur le bateau jorat
consommer moins de bois donc j'aurais
pris moins de temps alors massés sur les
plages et j'aurais peut-être sauvé mon
mât de l'invasion des termites
ce système hla hla s'est développée par
une biologiste
c'est un système de culture à petite
échelle de micro algues comestibles
ces microalgues comme la la chlorelle ou
la spiruline c'est des bombes contre la
malnutrition
elles sont bourrés de vitamines et de
minéraux donc ça ça m'aurait résolu mes
problèmes de malnutrition
ce système là on l'a trouvé sur youtube
c'est des étudiants en inde qu'il
développe
c'est un système hyper ingénieux pour
recycler des déchets plastiques en
carburant en fait c'est une cocotte
minute dans lequel on met des gros des
déchets plastiques
on fait chauffer et à plus de 400 degrés
le plastique émet un gaz qu on filtre et
qu'on danse et ça fait directement un
carburant qui est proche du gasoil sur
toutes les îles désertes où je me suis
arrêté les plages étaient remplis de
déchets plastiques
chaque seconde dans le monde j'ai appris
plus tard on jette plus de 200 kg de
plastique dans les océans
ça fait eu un déchet qu'on pourrait
considérer comme dans nos ressources
énormes ce dernier exemple c'est une
entreprise qu'il a développée pour les
cyclistes pour qu'ils puissent remplir
leur gourde en pédalant en fait j'aurais
pu m'en inspirer parce que alors c'est
un petit panneau solaire qui est relié à
un module pelletier c'est un espèce de
radiateur mais qui fait du froid l'air
passe à travers ce radiateur et
l'humidité de l'air se condense sur ce
petit radiateur à froid et goutte après
goutte ça remplit la gourde moi
j'utilise est un système à osmose
inverse qui prend énormément d'énergie
pour dessaler l'eau de mer en eau douce
et j'aurais pu gagner beaucoup de temps
et d'énergie grâce à un système comme ça
bref vous l'avez compris c'est pas le
nombre de solutions qui manquent et
j'aurais pu très facilement atteindre
mon objectif d'autonomie et avec
l'équipe on a compris que ce qui avait
manqué c'est pas un manque de
compétences je suis ingénieur est assez
bricoleur
j'avais les capacités de réussir c'est
pas un manque de temps ou des espaces
sur le bateau
c'est pas un manque d'outils ou encore
moins d'argent c'est juste que il ya des
solutions qui existaient mais j'ignorais
complètement leur existence
la raison pour laquelle je vous raconte
cette histoire c'est que pour moi elle
illustre très bien
un vrai problème qui a dans le monde qui
concerne des millions de personnes
là des millions de personnes qui ont des
problèmes de malnutrition d'accès à
l'eau à l'énergie à la nourriture
à côté il existe des solutions qui sont
taillés sur mesure qui sont
développables localement avec les moyens
du bord et qui répondent à ses besoins
de base mais que les gens n'ont pas
accès à ces solutions là des gens des
solutions pas de connexion
imaginez si demain on mettait plus de
force plus d'énergie plus de moyens dans
la recherche et dans l'innovation sur
ces technologies là si demain il n'y
avait pas 50 solutions comme ça mais
mille et que ces mille 6000 technologies
étaient rendues plus accessibles était
mieux diffuser et était en open source
ça veut dire que demain n'importe qui
dans le monde pourra choisir parmi tout
ce panel de technologies celles qui
correspondent au mieux à leurs besoins
alors ressources alors savoir faire
locaux à leur culture à leur économie
locale et à leur vision du progrès du
preuve de leur propre programme en fait
c'est l'idée de partager des
technologies à un niveau global pour
stimuler le développement au niveau
local et je suis convaincu que c'est ça
qui peut nous faire aller vers un monde
qui est non seulement plus juste plus
équitable aussi qu'ils respectent mieux
la nature mais alors pour ça il faut
faire un peu ce que facebook a fait pour
le partage de données personnelles ce
que wikipédia à faire pour le partage de
de lancer tout est dit ou ce que les
plateforme de crowdfunding ont fait pour
le mécénat
il faut faire une plateforme
collaborative de d'innovation et de
partage de cette technologie essentielle
à l'homme on travaille sur ce modèle là
avec mon association ou en fait on a
fait une plateforme de recherche
collaborative sur les low tech où on met
en réseau des entrepreneurs locaux qui
connaissent bien le terrain les
ressources et les besoins
on les met en réseau avec des mac gyver
des géo trouvetou des gens qui dans leur
garage ou dans des fables à buno des
workshops savent développer des
prototypes
en fait ça faire de la recherche low
cost la r&d low cost avec des étudiants
d'écoles d'ingénieurs ou design partout
autour du monde tous les ans il ya des
étudiants qui doivent mener des sujets
de recherche
encadrés par leurs professeurs et en
lien aussi avec des entreprises même des
entreprises de domaine très high tech
parce qu'en général les innovations low
tech sont directement des déclinaisons
d'innovation high tech
et donc pour ça après pour diffuser
toutes ces innovations parce que ça ça
booste l'innovation dans les lots tech
on a organisé une grande expédition
autour du monde qui démarre l'année
prochaine ou en fait à bord d'un grand
catamaran on va inviter à tour de rôle
tous les inventeurs des inventions les
plus pertinentes de la plateforme qui
vont venir à tour de rôle installé leur
système donc le bateau va accueillir
tous ces systèmes toutes celles au tec
et devenir au fil des trois ans du tour
du monde de plus automne de plus en plus
autonome en eau en énergie en nourriture
etc et diffuser ses systèmes au plus de
monde possible et à chaque escale fait
agrandir la communauté et de
bénéficiaires et de contributeurs
bon pour ça il faut rassembler pas mal
de monde
et du coup j'ai préparé un petit appel
que je vais vous faire est alors en fond
on va lancer une petite musique parce
que j'ai des réalisateurs récemment pour
un film et j'ai compris que la musique
ce domaine est vachement de poids la
parole êtes prêts
chercheurs ingénieurs macgyver géo
trouvetou retraités étudiants mécène
entreprises badauds du web ong
entrepreneurs de tous les pays unissez
vos forces pour innover et partager des
technologies vital accessibles et utiles
au plus grand nombre pour que chaque
personne dans le monde puisse
s'approprier localement des technologies
sur mesure pour qu'ensemble on
construise le monde de demain
nota bene et qu'on répare aussi un peu
le monde d'hier
merci on te l'a connu un très fort s'il
vous plaît